the game was wild unbelievable headline
kevin durant's going to new york right
is that the is that the oh wait a minute
that is the latest headline uh
and then uh you want to finish the
headline oh yeah he's going to new york
for doctor evaluations on his injured
right achilles there you go
there you go uh joining me here on the
rich eisen show three-time nba champion
now an
agent with the warren wasserman media
group the executive vice president and
managing executive on behalf of casey
uh for his media group good to see you
bj armstrong it's great to see you all
right let's get right into this because
you heard what i had to say in the first
segment of this show then you sit down
and you um what's the word for it you
were
um surprised to hear that maybe
people are criticizing nick nurse for
taking that time out with three minutes
to go
and then everything changed from there
on out why why do you profess
a little bit of surprise on that front
bj well
you know when you watch how the game was
being played last night
you know they were clawing and fighting
to get back in the game they were down
10 11 points in a significant part of
this game
and this wasn't a game where it was
going back and forth season you know who
was exchanging
uh within the game so for them they had
to ex
spend a lot of effort and energy just to
get back in the game
right you have a i'm going to say a 12
to 15 point swing
during that time when they're down 10 11
they go up what
six they go up six yes um so that's a 16
17 point swing and i thought at that
time because of the energy that was
that they had to expend to get back in
the game that it was a great
time out because you give your you give
your players an opportunity
to regroup kind of get them back into
the focus of let's close this game we
haven't
it wasn't a game where they had control
of the game all game that was their
first i recall that was their first lead
during the course of the the game
and if you're going to win a game at
that stage defensively you have to get a
stop
right offensively the only thing that i
saw that really bothered me during the
course of that
that run there was kyle laurie drives to
the basket and didn't get a shot up at a
critical moment of the game
even if it gets blocked just get a shot
up he throws it out to i think it was
marcus oh
it's a turnover that to me was more
critical than the timeout because you
always want to get up a shot if you get
up a shot you might get an offensive
rebound you might get a tip in
or more importantly you might get in and
you can start the shot clock over so
i thought at that time was a good time
out to give his team an opportunity
to say you know what we have to get a
good shot up every time down
and defensively we have to get a stop
which they never got to stop at the
waning moments of the game but what
about the idea that kerr
your former teammate he had his back
against the wall the reason why
kawhi went off on that 10-0 personal run
and did take the lead and that you know
it it it it caused kurt take a couple of
timeouts in it
leaving him with only one timeout left
he could not stop that run
towards the end of it because he's not
going to use his last timeout with three
minutes to go
instead nick nurse because he didn't
want to lose
a couple he didn't want to lose the
timeout that he was going to lose if he
didn't call it
because they were going to be under
three minutes he's the one who stopped
he's the one who gave the warriors also
a chance to regroup
and get a blow here and and we all saw
what happened
after that yeah well you have to you
have to stop the other team
and to me the the heart and soul of
both teams is their ability to get a
stop you know you can score as many
points as you want it wasn't a lot of
point score last night if you compare
them to the
the four previous games but defensively
you have to have your guys
in sync to get a stop at that stage of
the game and the warriors were able to
score
and that to me was the deciding factor
of the game it wasn't
about what i was doing offensively you
know that last possession for the
toronto raptors to me was a
that was a that was a a great defensive
sequence because you looked at the
warriors and what the warriors did
they guarded kara kawhi with three
players they had clay on them
then they bring andre iguodala at a very
unique angle
and then draymond is guarding three
people on the other side
uh you know he's he's guarding van fleet
he's guarding
marcus oh and he gets out and recovers
he even blocked the shot on larry
so you know that they
what they were doing they say we have to
get a stop in order to win this game
and i think the raptors were doing the
same we can focus in on the offensive
end but defensively
look if you have a chance to win at a
championship level
you have to stop the other team at some
point and they weren't able to do it and
i say they the toronto raptors weren't
able to do it they just needed one stop
that's all they needed was one stop last
night they win the game
but overall you know what they had a
chance to win it
if you say hey we got a chance to win it
with one shot at the end i'm gonna take
those chances and last night they didn't
make that shot so
here we are going into game six bj
armstrong here on the rich eisen show
do you think durant should have played
last night
i have such mixed emotions but the the
answer is no
um you know i've i've dealt with this
many times as a
as an agent i dealt with it as a player
myself you know i've had six surgeries
playing and if i could
tell my if i could go back in time and
tell my younger self i probably wouldn't
have played
because there was there's two sides to
every every
uh athlete you know there's the player
that wants to play
that's that's a warrior wants to go out
there and then there's the person
and looking back on it you know i had
like four or five surgeries where i know
i
probably shouldn't have come back to
play looking back on it now as a 50 a 51
year old man
but back then i wanted to play i wanted
to be a part of the team
kevin durant you know
i wish and i'm sure he did i'm probably
sure he could have reached out to former
players or people who've been in this
situation
my answer to him is no he shouldn't have
played there's too much
at risk and what i mean by too much at
risk is this young man i know wanted to
get out there and be in a place where we
all dream of playing we want to play in
the nba finals we want to play for a
championship
but you have to respect the game itself
and the game is you don't just take a
month off and then come back and play in
the finals
right there's no way for you to get your
conditioning there's no way to get the
reaction but more importantly
like your body that's why we have a
month of training camp
to get ready for the season you just
don't take a month off
and especially when it's a lower
extremity injury and then all of a
sudden
come out there and be ready to play at
the level that that game is being played
at but
again that was his call and
you know i had a player that i
represented that i represent currently
still
is uh derrick rose and
those are some of the most difficult
conversations that i've had
because you're dealing with human nature
the part the the d
rose character wanted to play
but derrick rose i had to talk to
derrick rose because derrick rose is the
person that has to live with this
decision
for the rest of his life and that's
always tough because the player sometime
is the most dominant of the
personalities and
i just felt awful for kevin durant
because you knew in his heart of heart
that he wanted to play he wanted to
contribute he wanted to be there
but at the same time the respect that
you have to give this game and these
athletes and what's you have to really
prepare yourself for that moment
is you know sometimes you just have to
say you know what i want to do it but
the body won't allow me to do it at that
time well you say again b.j armstrong
here on the show you say you watch every
game twice
yes he said okay so then the first time
you watch the game live
were you thinking after the 11 point
first quarter seeing the
warriors get a clear jolt looking like a
totally different team and a must-have
game were you sitting there thinking he
still shouldn't be playing right now
well when i saw how he was running up
and down the court
i didn't like it i didn't like his gate
i didn't like how he was extending
and i saw him moving gingerly as he was
going up the court
he wasn't exploding up the court he was
just kind of
taking his time he was walking into his
shots now he made him
got the results he was looking for but i
look at things a
player's ability to react like you know
the one play i think he got knocked down
on the defense i think his very first
foul
like he just didn't react to the play
and to me that's a sign
defensively is where you are the slowest
to recover because it requires you to
react offensively i know what i'm going
to do i know if the ball is going to
swing swing
i can step into it and shoot but
defensively he didn't really react
now he got up he popped up uh he took
the
you know the physicality took the blow
but i just didn't like how he was moving
i didn't like his gait as he was
exploding up the floor i mean he's a
he is like a beautiful athlete meaning
he runs he extends he covers ground
he was if you just watch like the first
minute or two of the game he was
he was walking gingerly and i just
didn't like that when i saw the first
couple minutes or so of the game so then
keep your agent hat on for a second bj
what's
what's rich klim and his agent thinking
today do you think well i think you have
to think about the person right you know
at this point
of the game right now you can't cry or
or
you know worry about what happened you
have to deal with the situation because
you have a young man right now that has
to deal
with the decision whatever happens you
know i don't know if it's been announced
no he's he's going to new york to get an
opinion on it chris is that what you're
saying right
he's going to new york to get evaluated
which means the mri must have come back
one would
i i guess we shouldn't sit here yeah
yeah webmd or try and speculate here
i don't want to break a hepa law either
you know but i mean so
so i i'm in in all seriousness though i
mean
i mean july 1 is sitting there right and
and i'm just again i'm wondering do you
go to the
the front office i mean because
obviously what you're saying last night
from what you saw kerr had to see it too
yeah you see
all the assistants who know the game bob
myers the general manager who
who was very emotional you know do we
have that sound bite do we have that if
you don't mind
here here this is a portion of what bob
uh had to say
last night the general manager of the
warriors
kevin um
i don't believe there's anybody to blame
but i understand is this world
and um if you have to
you can blame me i run our basketball
operations department
i mean you must deal you've dealt with
him before obviously you represent
javel mcgee and you you had um draymond
in your arsenal for quite some time yes
what'd you make of that i i feel for bob
and because that's a tough situation
you're dealing with
players who want to play you're dealing
with
the ramifications of everyone knows how
important this is
everyone's caught up within the moment
but at the same time
you know you have to deal with the
person and knowing
of you know what he's talking about is
kevin durant the person right there
and yeah he's a great player yes he
helps us win games yes
he's one of the all-time greats but in
the end you feel for a person
because you know what that what that
means to him basketball
means something to kevin durant and you
saw the emotions
of things we can't see as fans in
and as an agent i see that all the time
i don't worry about the player these
players are
wonderfully gifted they're talented but
the people
and um i can only imagine
what that must have been like for bob
and
rich kleinman his family and for him
of what that must have been one step
must have that situation must have been
like
in that moment after the game but you
know what you have to move on
hopefully um well hopefully he will get
the support because the warriors are a
terrific organization
they will give him the emotional support
um
the mental support that he needs
obviously physically he'll be able to
rehab but
that's a tough one and i'm and bob that
was just tough that's tough to come out
for anyone that you really
you know these guys are with each other
you know practically all day to see one
of your brothers go down in that fashion
when you know he's trying to give
everything he can for the good of the
whole it
was a tough call was a tough call for
him in the organization last night b.j
armstrong here
on the rich eisen show and again the the
durant of it all
and and his legacy and his free agency
and all that stuff we can place to the
side for a moment
i i personally think that that's going
to be the subject of conversation
starting tomorrow
as we're waiting for game six to show up
on thursday night
uh but all that said when game six hits
um
the raptors were killing the warriors on
the pick and roll just
absolutely with the switches and the the
the number of times that boogie cousins
would find himself on the island at the
top of the three-point arc and sometimes
draymond would be up there too
i mean the raptors were torturing him on
that front do you think that
when it's all said and done and the
emotions of game five
calms down having seen the game now
twice that the raptors have the warriors
potentially on the ropes
still well yes the raptors have them on
the ropes because of now you just have
able bodies
you know you need bodies to go out there
and play and you know
i boogie found himself on the offensive
end he you know he scored some points
and he really did some things he did
some things well out there on the
offensive end
defensively though steve kerr and his
staff they're very concerned about him
because every time he's on the floor
they attack him they attack him and
that's a problem and you saw steve
kerr go away from boogie last night i
mean he went to bogut
early then he went to kevon looney
and he started draymond at the center
position but out of necessity they had
to go to boogie and give boogie credit
as a professional he responded under
duress
in a hostile environment so i give him
credit for being ready being engaged
but that's going to be a problem for
them is what are they going to do
defensively when boogie is on the floor
because the raptors are going to attack
him and put him in every defensive
sequence in the screen and roll and then
uh conversely i
i know iguodala made the big shot of
game two yes
he couldn't he couldn't make a shot
offensively last night and kerr had to
remove him essentially towards the end
of the game on the offensive end
but when it came time to wrap things up
on the defensive end
he was remarkable again so
that seemed to be an issue for kerr it's
amazing how they got out of there with a
win last night well it was amazing but
last time i was here rich you know nick
nurse went to a zone and won
the boxing one yes last night he went to
a diamond in two
for one possession and i was like
this is this guy is great um so
you know he's give him credit he's
trying
and they're doing things on the
defensive end now now that they know
kevin durant
is not going to play i think defensively
they will come out with a plan knowing
what they have to do
because kevin durant's presence on the
floor changed everything for them
it changed how they were defending they
put kawhi leonard
initially on kevin durant it changed
their spacing changed their rotation
and i think the warriors benefited from
that and we'll see how they
respond in game six it'll be very
emotional it'll be a great game i'm sure
you and i will both be glued to our
televisions watching and i might not
watch it twice like you but
i gotta i gotta watch to see what these
guys are doing so uh
but it was it was a great game it was an
epic game last night and um
you know but i just in the end it was a
bittersweet moment because you feel for
kevin durant and
hopefully and you know knowing that our
prayers will be with him and he'll fight
through this
and and you know the um unspoken
um word and the
just the the emotions of a game and how
that can potentially carry over
it's tough to not sit here and think and
again you i know you said nick nurse
understands his team better than i would
sitting here
and i know you're saying that the amount
of energy that was expanded to just
get that six point lead was significant
enough right that he felt the need to
call a timeout
it's just tough to sit here and not
think
that that was their last best shot
potentially
to win this whole thing i understand
that they're healthier and i understand
that they're they're not a team that's
going to fold that they have a
certain mental fortitude that is
significant and they take it from number
two
and they all soak it in and their kauai
lead team it just feels that way to me
right well
yes and no but i will say this you know
first you have to respect the word the
warriors are not going to go down
without a fight
they've proven lord right you got to
knock them out
okay you're going to have to knock them
out
in the end the warriors made such a
commitment to kawhi leonard
the work like it wasn't like the raptors
came back
kawhi leonard had a 10-0 run that it was
basically
one versus five kawhi was like it's
amazing like it was it was like one of
those moments like
it's one of those wow you're just
watching this young man
basically pick his moment which was
perfect timing to pick his moment where
he was going
to elevate his game to an entirely
different level
that no one else on the floor could play
at and he had like a
a stretch there you just like it was
kawhi
versus the warriors and kauai was
winning that game and the warriors
made a commitment to not only guard him
with uh klay thompson andre was going to
come in double
and draymond green was like the third
defender
so clearly they are aware of
how magnificent of a player kawhi
leonard is
and it's important that you allow the
other players to say because i was one
of those guys
you're it's it's only normal for them to
only watch
a michael jordan like i had to catch
myself times from time to time saying
oh i got to play because michael jordan
was just doing things all by himself
so it could have been coach nurse could
have said look guys
we have to get engaged the other four
guys to figure out what we need to do
and offensively to get themselves
organized because kawhi leonard was
going on a run
all by himself which was like this was
an incredible thing to watch last night
so then ask a poll question of b.j
armstrong as we send him out into the
los
angeles day sir what do you got over
there chris ask him
who wins the championship bj warriors
raptors
raptors are going to win this um i just
think because they have the bodies
um and they have the youth i think they
just have
more healthy bodies but i i will say
this
game seven can be anybody's game
game seven i i think the emotion will
carry uh
here in in game six um i think that's
gonna be a tough game for the raptors to
win
but they're certainly a very capable
team because defensively they will give
the effort necessary
um but i said i'm going to say the
raptors i'm going to say the raptors in
seven
i think this i think this goes seven and
it's anybody's game but i think
with the energy that's needed to do what
the warriors
need to do i just don't know if they
have enough bodies to do it i mean
that's you're asking these guys to play
40 plus minutes for the next three games
and play
almost mistake free basketball which i
think is is very difficult
but um it's certainly shaping up to be a
heck of a series and i know it's going
to be a great game there thursday
in oracle and um we'll see what happens
you know who'd have thought it before
the nba finals if i
told you that to avoid the crapshoot of
a seventh game at home the raptors would
have to win a third straight at oracle
it's crazy i mean this whole series has
been absolutely nuts
thanks for coming on b.j oh thank you
really appreciate it it's bj armstrong
right here
for more of the rich eisen show tune to
audience channel 239 on directv
for free on br live or download the rich
eisenshow app